[Musique]
nous sommes le 28 mars 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette édition du 7 8 et
les invités émission consacrée à celles
et ceux qui font l'actualité dans le
département dans un instant rencontre
avec pascal be dance et le directeur
délégué de l'estac à l'école
d'ingénieurs de montigny-le-bretonneux
nous a reçus à quelques jours de son
séminaire sur l'espace quel espace dans
20 ans et nous livrera sa vision et puis
elle nous évoquerons aussi les demi
finales des championnats de france de
gymnastique artistique féminine avec la
vice-présidente du club d'elancourt
maurepas en charge de l'organisation
ainsi que mathilde de terre l'une des
compétitrices à qui tentera de se
qualifier les 1er et 2 avril
bonsoir à vous deux et bienvenue sur ce
plateau mathilde de membres de l'équipe
national de première division et morgane
goulard qui est vice présidente du club
d'elancourt maurepas alors à quelques
jours de cette compétition quelles sont
les chances du club et l'on espère
importante
en tout cas on s'est préparé pour que
soient les gimont les entraîneurs on a
on organisait la préparation pour avoir
toutes nos chances donc l'objectif c'est
de qualifier dizaine de jeunes loups est
à peu près dix gymnastes on en avait 13
ou 14 l'année dernière
je pense qu'on avait abusé attendra pas
cette année mais en tout cas dit ce
serait johns creek lui elles seront 24
du club à y participer
on va développer les enjeux de cette
rencontre dans quelques minutes
auparavant direction donc l'estaca à
montigny le bretonneux
l'école organise le lundi 3 avril un
séminaire sur la thématique quel espace
dans 20 ans la des rencontres qui sont
réservés aux étudiants et aux
spécialistes de l'aérospatiale la
rencontre avec le directeur délégué de
l'école c'est avec nicolas gandrille
l'astronaute thomas p ce qui représente
actuellement l'excellence de
l'ingénierie française à bord de la
station internationale
une excellence que l'on retrouve
notamment à l'estaca et nous sommes en
compagnie de pascal vit dans son
directeur délégué bonsoir bonsoir
alors qu'est ce que cela vous inspire
laventure de thomas pesquet à bord de
cette station internationale
alors thomas pesquet c'est l'espace
d'aujourd'hui puisqu'il est en ce moment
dans l'espace à la hausse 1,2
la station spatiale internationale et
ils pensent à nous puisqu'il a
enregistré un message vidéo concernant
l'événement le séminaire espace du
groupe isa et qui va se tenir à l'estaca
la semaine prochaine justement ce
séminaire c'est lundi 3 avril
quel est le programme concernant ces
discussions qui vont avoir lieu pendant
toute la semaine
alors le programme se déroule en quatre
temps premier temps le message de thomas
pesquet un deuxième temps de débats et
de conférences autour du thème quel
espace dans 20 ans un troisième temps où
les étudiants vont travailler vont
réfléchir dans l'est sur les innovations
les innovations qui auront lieu dans les
deux décennies à venir
et puis un dernier temps avec des
visites mais visite où les étudiants
iront parcourir les centres des yvelines
les centres de la région parisienne qui
travaillent dans le spatial
alors quel centre par exemple vous allez
visiter alors deux centres donc très
proche d'ici un airbus defence and space
à elancourt le latmos qui est un
laboratoire d'observation de la terre à
guyancourt les sites aussi et d'airbus a
frôlé answers donc aux mureaux et puis à
vernon et puis également un site
nucléaire vide alors il ya l'aspect
militaire il ya l'aspect de
l'aérospatiale différentes thématiques
quelles sont les disciplines qui vont
être abordées les thématiques précises
alors les thématiques sont sont très
larges elles couvrent des sujets qui
sont très concret maintenant le
numérique les télécoms ou le thé comme
spatiale l'année vers la navigation par
satellite avec gps le système américain
et puis maintenant galil galileo le
système européen qui est dans la
constellation de satellites est
maintenant en orbite et qui sera mis en
service d'ici 2020 tous les sujets
également militaire donc de
renseignement d'observation
et puis également les sujets liés plutôt
à la science donc l'observation de la
terre
quelles données on peut avoir pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique tous les aspects donc assez
concret de l'espace d'aujourd'hui alors
quels sont les différents organismes à
l'initiative de cet événement
alors cet événement est organisé par le
groupe isa et le groupe isa et rassemble
quatre écoles les quatre écoles de
l'excellence dans le secteur
aéronautique et spatial donc super héros
qui est à toulouse
l'école de l'ère kita salon de provence
lance mc et à poitiers puis l'estac a
donc à saint quentin et puis à laval
puisqu'on à 2,6 à lhassa car alors les
objectifs de ces séminaires de ces
discussions tout au long de la semaine
quelles sont elles alors les objectifs
tourne autour de quel espace dans 20 ans
donc l'espace a toujours fait rêver
depuis la conquête spatiale premier
homme sur la lune
la sonde rosetta fila et et puis on voit
bien que 20 ans et 2037 en fait ça peut
sembler loin un peu comme une date de
science fiction mais en fait c'est
demain pour nos étudiants donc travaillé
au tourisme spatial travailler au
nouveau lanceur les danseurs
réutilisables aux nouveaux satellites et
puis tous ces aspects d'applications
donc notamment on voit qu'on a de plus
en plus maintenant de start up 1 qui se
créent dans le secteur du spatial
spatiale était précédemment réservé aux
grandes agences à la nasa l'agencé
spatiale européenne le cnes et puis
aujourd'hui on a des start up qui se
créent pour intervenir dans le spatial
peut-être des astronautes qui vont
sortir de l'estaca alors oui oui alors
les astronautes la plupart des
astronautes sont sortis des écoles du
groupe isa est un donc thomas pesquet
sortie supaéro nous avons eu ici à
l'estac 1 il ya peu de temps une
conférence de michel tonini par exemple
qui est venu expliquer son expérience
puisqu'il a voté il a volé à la fois
donc sur des services
des engins russes et puis américain qui
est également un ancien élève de l'école
de l'air donc le prochain un étudiant on
espère bien seront de l'estaca alors il
ya thomas pesquet qui fait l'actualité
mais c'est aussi la nasa qui fait
d'actualité notamment avec l' annonce de
la découverte de cette nouvelle
exoplanète qui auraient des certaines
priorités similaires à la terre
est ce que ce genre de découverte ce
genre d'étude permet de développer des
voies de recherche pour les doctorants
présent à l'estaca alors bien sûr le
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure du numérique
des applications concrètes business mais
un aspect majeur dans notre activité
spatiale c'est la recherche c'est la
science on aura d'ailleurs une table
ronde orienté sur les aspects
scientifiques donc qui sera présidée par
xavier pasco qui est le président de la
fondation pour la recherche scientifique
avec francis rocard qui est un
astrophysicien et qui nous parlerons de
tout ces nouveaux enjeux liés à la
science
1 et donc les exoplanètes tout la
découverte scientifique autour de
l'espace parce qu'albi dans merci alors
ce séminaire quel espace dans 20 ans
c'est lundi 3 avril à 9h30 un événement
réservé aux étudiants de l'estaca et aux
spécialistes de l'aérospatiale mais vous
pourrez retrouver des résumés des
premiers échanges des premières réunions
sur tv fil 78 dans nos journaux et le
7-8 les invités se poursuit nous
remettons les pieds sur terre à présent
les le week-end des 1er et 2 avril le
club de gymnastique et d'elancourt
maurepas organise donc au palais des
sports les demi finales des championnats
de france de gymnastique artistique
féminine
morgane colas 1re vice-présidente du
club c'est une compétition majeure qui
permet de se qualifier il ya un enjeu
véritable pour les championnats de
france individuels
c'est la compétition la plus importante
en individuel sur une saison
génique qui permet donc de se qualifier
sur les championnats de france qui
auront lieu à cognac le week-end du
limay et en fait voilà les trois
premières ou la première déjà catégorie
qui est sélectionné d'office et après
c'est un classement vertical sur la
france en fonction des totaux de points
que ça veut dire que les athlètes vos
athlètes se préparent tout au long de
l'année pour ce rendez vous oui pour ce
rendez-vous et l'autre qui sera en
équipe fin avril mais globalement il
prépare pour ces deux rendez-vous
principe alors mathilde justement matip
de terre vous avez 19 ans gymnase de
division 2 nationale une comment vous
êtes préparés parce que vous ressentez
un petit peu de pression basse est la
première condition de l'année donc ça en
riant comme un peu de pression après on
sent comme l'a dit morgan
on se prépare depuis le début de l'année
est là depuis deux trois semaines fait
que de répéter nos mouvements donc d'un
moment ça devrait aller il y aura 300
gymnastes en tout
oui on précise que c'est ouvert au
public bien sûr pour venir les soutenir
c'est au palais des sports à elancourt
on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
qu'est ce qui fait la différence
justement qu'est ce qui fera la
différence bath et les chutes
c'est une chute ça arrive facilement
même si à l'entraînement elle fait
toujours très bien en même pas trois
secondes on peut justement chuté et ça
coûte cher du coup sa fin les
différences se feront en fonction des
jeux de louper une qualification pour
une fille avant avocat me s'élance
justement sur les différents praticable
vous sentez vous vous dites là c'est mal
parti ou comment sur le bas-côté son
côté du terrain vous vivez sa bâche afin
je pense que et elle et ses entraîneurs
voient déjà des débuts au moment où
elles rendent sur la grèce dans quel
état d'esprit elle est si elle est
concentrée sylvain tu me l'as content
mais je pense que c'était le début du
mouvement le rôle du club c'est
justement de de s'assurer que toutes les
conditions soient réunies de rassurer
les athlètes qui vont passer
oui notre rôle c'est clairement de
préparer les athlètes au mieux ça passe
par l'entraînement mais ça passe aussi
par les conditions d'entraînement et les
conditions psychologiques des athlètes
etc
qu'est ce que vous êtes en bonne
condition psychologique pour moi aussi
parce que le club a bien aidé à tout ça
oui ton et bien traités a beaucoup
pratiqué au sein du club est en cours
mais pas depuis quand depuis 2010 qu'est
ce qui vous a motivé à vous inscrire à
ce club vous l'avez vous souhaitez y
participer ou
on m'a dit d'aller là bas c'est un bon
club et du coup j'ai fait un test et
après je suis rentré au club le club de
maurepas il encourait l'encours maurepas
bénéficient de cette bonne réputation
mais il ya des clubs qui sont
redoutables à travers la france ou pas
hier à 300 gymnastes 8 dans l'île de
france il ya deux gros clubs il ya les
clubs je peux pas tous les citer mais
aux alentours dont il ya les clubs de
limay herblay francon midi le clama
enfin il ya plein de gros clubs aux
alentours et de l'autre côté du de
france aussi sur combs-la-ville mots etc
à des clubs si vous font peur pour la
compétition qui en tout cas son
redoutable vous observez week on
observera forcément pendant la
compétition après le but du jeu c'est
d'être concentré sur sa performance et
de à la fin de la compétition de se dire
qu'on a rien à regretter qu'on a donné
le meilleur de soi en général le club
elancourt maurepas s'en sort plutôt bien
sur ce genre de rendez vous en général
on arrive à qualifier voilà enfin d'à
peu près 10 gymnastes sur les
championnats de france individuels après
et des années avec des années sans hélas
le fait d'être à la maison justement bas
c'est vrai que ça va enfin je pense que
ça aide
d'une part d'avoir tous les supporters
qui sont tour à encourager des sur les à
gré sur lesquels on pratiquer toute
l'année
forcément est ce que ça vous ratio est
ce que ça vous angoisse de pratiquer à
la maison non ça rassure parce qu'on a
pas un
une adaptation à avoir par rapport aux à
gré des agressés ce sur lequel on
s'entraîne toute l'année du coup ça
favorise enfin c'est mieux que vous êtes
fin prête
oui aura encore des répétitions là il
nous reste de l'entraînement pour être
prête le jour j
ce sera le week-end des 1er 2 avril et
puis c'est un rendez-vous aussi
particulier puisque vous allez inaugurer
ce praticable que vous avez récupéré et
des jo de rio en 2016
rians praticable comment on avait
récupéré en fait à la sortie des jeux
olympiques le fournisseur officiel donc
de gymnastique gymnova avait six ou sept
praticable dédié aux jeux olympiques de
rio qui était utilisé sur place qui leur
vendaient à un prix défiant toute
concurrence par rapport au prix habituel
des praticables
et c'est vrai que l'armée a sauté sur
l'occasion parce que de toute façon il
nous en fallait un de ce type là puisque
les obligations maintenant il faut alors
c'est pas encore devenu obligatoire mais
en gros de l'énorme de la fédération
france fin de la fédération
internationale de gymnastique ont changé
et c'est vrai que c'est se pratique ap
qui utilisaient maintenant pour tous les
championnats de france
donc si on veut être préparé dans les
meilleures conditions pour la finale
nationale
l'objectif c'est de se préparer sur les
mêmes types d'agréer et qu'est ce que ça
change pour les gymnastes ça change
deux choses principales au niveau du
rebond elle peut prétendre à faire de
plus grosse difficulté c'est pour
beaucoup plus facile pour elle toute
mesure mais au niveau du rebond ça
change
et au niveau des traumatismes sur les
réceptions c'est beaucoup moins
traumatisante l'ancien praticable et
enfin nous qui avons pas mal de jeunes
gymnastes c'est important pour nous de
faire attention à leur intégrité
physique vous l'avez déjà testé oui on
l'a au club depuis fin février et vous
sentez la différence ah oui bah c'est
mieux pour pour les uns taille pour tout
ça c'est mieux un dernier mot cette
compétition demi-finale est ce qu'on
peut espérer voir un jour une grande
finale se déroulait sur saint quentin en
yvelines
bon on l'espère on a
c'est un projet qu'on a continent ce qui
nous tient à coeur donc on espère le
réaliser peut-être pour 2018 on aura
l'occasion bien sûr d'en reparler bonne
chance à votre club bien sûr et bonne
chance à vous pour cette compétition
nous y reviendrons au cours de notre
prochaine édition du 7 8 sports lundi à
partir de 19h15 sur notre antenne c'est
la fin du set 8 les invités pour ce
mardi
tout de suite les programmes se
poursuivre sur notre antenne et rendez
vous sur internet pour les replays
[Musique]